so the question is what is the future of
the Mediterranean and what is the rule
that the key actors the European Union
the Arab countries from Morocco to Syria
and the Gulf the GCC can play in the
future first let me tell you with a
personal anecdote that I'm very
supportive of the idea of a humidity
Iranian Union I'm Italian my wife is
creating my children are health European
health Arab so I think that's the way to
go unfortunately the view now these days
is a bit on the pessimistic side is the
glass-half-empty kind of view Europe has
no money so cannot transfer development
assistance to demography to and to a
magical to do to their board they are
aboard this tool by its own differences
by this war between Israel Palestine
that is the Lebanon Syria issue there
are a lot of administrative barriers
trade barriers and all these risks scare
the GCC countries the gun from investing
heavily in this union I kind of think
that the gloves helpful is a better
perspective the Arab world has what
Europe needs and Europe has what the
Arab world needs Europe as they know how
and era board has a dynamic population a
huge population growth organization
future consumption and energy production
think about how easily can energy
produced in the desert and export it to
Europe so this is the way the way to
solve and to look at the future is
having all these agents the European
Union there are bored and the Gulf see
together at the table and and and try to
do our address issues together that's
the way to go for example immigration is
they have you can look at at a half-full
or half-empty Alf empties is a problem
Europe cannot take more immigration
there is a brain drain in the Arab world
all this is true but the only way to
solve it is to have a policy that is
common and try to show Europe needs
brains and and the Arab world also needs
not to have a brain drain that is so
massive i was reading statistics Lebanon
has almost 40% of it skilled labor force
living Morocco is second with almost
twenty percent of course this is a big
big drain on the Arab world but also
this is what Europe needs so agreeing on
how to do it is something that needs to
be decided to gather energy
infrastructure reducing risks is all
something that can be done by Europe and
the Arab countries together maybe the
Arab League can help there to attract
the Gulf for in the future for investing
in this region that has huge perspective
is is if you can look at the region with
a healthful perspective is a 470 million
market with again a huge potential in
the Arab world organization dynamics
bring about energy consumption real
estate needs financial services needs so
banking and health insurance and life
insurance and and so basically Europe
again has the know-how and could come
and find a market and the Arab world can
provide
future prospect so I like this
optimistic view